pauline on le voit vous êtes à kiev où
la vie a repris et la circulation est
dense ce matin vous revenez de
borodianka c'est dans la région de la
capitale et vous avez constaté des
destructions massives
oui ça se trouve environ à une heure de
kiev en voiture et c'est vrai quand vous
arrivez abordant le cas vous ne pouvait
que constater les dégâts de la guerre
c'est assez impressionnant de voir tous
ces immeubles éventrés couvert de
ballons on voit on a pu même voir
certains endroits où vous voyez les mais
les machines à laver encore la vie en
fait qu'ils étaient là présente dans ces
immeubles juste avant les bombardements
pour vous rendre compte à 49 bâtiments
publics ont été détruits
390 maisons privées 14 immeubles ont
également été atteints et été détruits
ce qui fait en gros l'équivalent de 700
appartements avant la guerre dans cette
ville il y avait environ quatorze mille
habitants 7000 sont rentrés 1500 était
resté pendant la guerre on a pu discuter
avec anna qui a tout perdu lors des
bombardements elle avait fui juste
quelques jours après l'occupation russe
elle nous a expliqué avoir fui sous la
bombe à sous les bombardements avoué
avoir eu extrêmement peur elle est
rentrée une fois que les russes étaient
parties de la région avec son mari puis
quand elle est arrivée elle n'a pu que
constater les dégâts puisque son
appartement avait été entièrement
détruit elle a quand même pu récupérer
quelques objets avant de partir et le
lendemain figurez vous que la cage
d'escalier de son immeuble s'est
entièrement effondré elle vit
actuellement dans un préfabriqué des
frais fabriqués qui ont été installés
dans la ville de borodianka financé par
la pologne construit par des volontaires
ukrainien pour l'instant elle se dit
chanceuse malgré tout della et puis elle
dit attendre et espérer bien qu'un jour
on puisse tout reconstruire a beau rendu
en cas mais le gros problème et c'est ce
que nous a dit également le maire c'est
qu'ils attendent
attendent désespérément des financements
de la part de l'état mais ils le savent
il faudra sans doute attendre que la
guerre se termine pour avoir ces
financements pour pouvoir enfin
reconstruire